we already have the tools in our toolkit
to factor something like x squared plus
4x minus 5 and the way that we've
already thought about it is we said hey
let's think of two numbers that if we
were to take their product we get
negative 5 and if we were to add the two
numbers we get positive 4 and there's a
the fact that their product is negative
tells you one of them is going to be
positive and one of them is going to be
negative and so there's a couple of ways
you could think about it well you could
say well maybe one of the numbers is
negative one and then the other one is
positive five actually this one seems to
work negative 1 times 5 is negative 5
negative 1 plus 5 is positive 4 so this
one actually seems to work the other
option would have been since we're just
going to deal with the the factors of 5
and 5s a prime number the other option
would have been something like 1 and
negative 5 there's only two factors for
5 so 1 and negative 5 the product would
have been negative 5 but if you were to
add these two numbers you would have
gotten a negative 4 right over here so
we're going to go with this right over
here and so this tells us that if we
want to factor this using kind of the
tools that we already know about we will
get and let me let me write these
numbers in a different color so we can
keep track of them so negative 1 & 5 we
know that this would factor out to be X
X minus 1 X minus 1 x times X plus 5
times X plus 5 and you can verify this
for yourself that if you were to
multiply this out you will get x squared
plus 4x minus 5 you can even see this
here x times X is x squared
negative x plus 5 X is going to be 4x
and then negative 1 times 5 is negative
5
fair enough this is all a review for us
at this point now I want to talk tackle
something a little bit a little bit more
interesting let's say we wanted a factor
let's say we wanted to factor x squared
plus 4x y minus 5 y squared and at first
this looks really daunting all of a
sudden I've introduced a Y and a y
squared here I have two variables how
would I tack
but the important thing is to just take
a deep breath and realize that we're not
fundamentally doing something different
now the one little tricky thing I've
done when I've written it this way and I
encourage you to pause this and try this
on your own before I explain any further
but the one tricky thing I did right
over here is I wrote the X before the Y
and that tends to be the convention you
just write them kind of in alphabetical
order but if we want it in a form that's
a little bit closer to this and
something that we could that would fit
this mold a little bit more is if we if
we if we swap these two because then we
could write it as x squared plus 4y x
minus 5y squared and now it becomes
pretty clear that this 4y term right
over here this right over here is the
coefficient on the x-term the same way
that 4 was the coefficient on X right
here and this negative 5y squared
corresponds to the negative 5 right over
here so we can do the exact same thought
process let's think of 2 now not just
numbers they're going to have variables
at them let's think of two terms or two
expressions that if I multiply them I
get negative 5y squared and that when I
take the sum I get 4y
so let's think about how we could do
this so one option one option would be
positive let's say positive Y and
positive Y and negative 5y so where
would this take us positive Y times
negative 5y would indeed be equal to
negative 5y squared but then if I add Y
to negative 5y I'm going to get negative
4y so this doesn't work let's see if we
swap the two the two signs so what about
negative Y and positive 5y well here if
I take the product of negative Y and 5y
it will be negative 5y squared and if I
take the sum negative Y + 5 y it will be
positive 4y so we know how to factor it
now so once again let me put this in the
same color so this is I'm going to put
in this this move color this light
purple and this I'll put it in a darker
purple so now we know how to factor this
this is going to be and this is the same
exact mold that we did up here same
exact idea this is going to be X instead
of just a minus 1 here now we've
factored here we factored into a
negative 1 and 5 here we factor to a
negative y + 5 y so instead of a
negative 1 it's going to be a negative Y
X minus y times X plus 5y X plus 5y and
we can verify that when you multiply
this out it indeed does equal x squared
+ 4 XY minus 5y so let me do that here
just so we can know for sure so x times
X is going to be x squared X let me do
everything in a different color
x times 5y is going to be plus 5 X Y
then negative Y times X is negative Y X
and then finally finally if we take and
I'm running out of colors if we take
negative Y times 5y that's negative 5y
squared and now we just have to simplify
we have to combine these middle two
terms right over here and at first it
looks a little bitter this is X Y this
is YX not so obvious but we just have to
rewrite it this is the same thing as 5
YX minus y X and so here you're saying
look I have 5y X's and I'm going to
subtract Y X's so I'm gonna have 4y X's
so this is just going to be 4y X's I
have 5y X's take out another YX I'm
going to have 4y X's so this is going to
be x squared plus 4y x minus 5y squared
and it all works out